et dans ce sens public j'ouvre tout de
suite notre second débats des bas
prospectives que je vous propose sur
l'avenir du conservatisme en France
dimanche vous le savez le parti a l'air
les républicains on va désigner son
nouveau président sera-t-il pour autant
conservateur que signifie ce mot et ce
courant de pensée est-il réservé à la
droite on va répondre évidemment à
toutes ces questions mais d'abord cette
question le mot conservateur ou
conservatisme est-il tabou en France
Sandra serkira
on dit la France de plus en plus à
droite DLR à Éric Zemmour assiste-t-on à
une montée du conservatisme ce courant
porté par la nostalgie du passé qui
refuse les ruptures ou les évolutions
trop rapides Georges Pompidou parlait de
changement dans la continuité non
réponse politologue cela peut sembler
paradoxal mais en France selon lui cela
reste marginal aucun courant politique
ne peut et ne veut être clairement
identifié comme conservateur ce n'est
pas une identité politique reconnue
conservateurs et pendant très longtemps
la droite est le même
se flatter tout vouloir bousculer les
conservatifs pour moderniser le pays etc
une des choses remarquables si vous
voulez en France par rapport à d'autres
démocraties la droite ne veut pas être
conservatrice être conservateur serait
donc tabou en France
un courant trop méconnu et caricaturé
pour ce chercheur la droite dans sa
recomposition politique aurait tout
intérêt à assumer son conservatisme pour
que les LR puissent retrouver de leur
influence face à l'extrême droite
qu'est-ce que la droite la question qui
se pose et oui je pense peut-être que le
qualifié de conservateur et être
conservateur est plus plus porteur parce
qu'elle conservateur on peut être en
partie gouvernement et conservateur le
conservateur reste modérée et en même
temps un conservateur est vraiment de
droite donc elle se placerait bien en
tout cas elle pourrait dire d'un côté je
ne suis pas le Front National et de
l'autre je ne suis pas non plus en
marche ou Renaissance maintenant c'est
peut-être l'alternative qui permettra le
mieux de garder les républicains comme
une un particulier gouvernement et comme
un parti de droite modérée à l'étranger
aussi les parties conservateurs sont en
crise et perdent des voies ils sont
devenus incapables comme au Danemark ou
en Suède de gouverner seul dans de
nombreux cas et doivent parfois chercher
le soutien de l'extrême droite
je vous présente tout de suite mes
invités Frédéric matoncti bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes professeur de
sciences politiques à l'Université Paris
impensé on Sorbonne auteur de ce livre
comment sommes-nous sommes-nous devenus
réac publier aux éditions Fayard
Laetitia strange Bonnard bonsoir
bienvenue à vous aussi essayer ce
rédactrice en chef des pages débat et ID
au magazine L'Express auteur de ce livre
vous avez dit conservateur point
d'interrogation publié aux éditions du
Cerf Bruno cotreesse politologue bonsoir
bienvenue à vous aussi chercheur au CNRS
et aussi pof et Laetitia cru pas
éditoris politique évidemment toujours à
mes côtés rebonsoir Laetitia je commence
tout simplement en ouvrant le
dictionnaire voilà la lettre C comme
conservateur
se dit de quelqu'un d'un parti politique
caractérisé par l'attachement aux
valeurs et aux structures
traditionnelles et par l'hostilité au
changement attachement valeur hostilité
au changement est-ce que c'est aussi
votre définition Frédéric matanti moi
j'ai du mal avec le conservateur c'est
d'ailleurs pourquoi j'avais choisi
réactionnaire pour décrire un certain
nombre de phénomènes parce que ça me
permettait de dire les réactionnaires se
sont ceux qui veulent revenir en arrière
à un monde que parfois il idéalise et
qui n'a pas forcément existé alors et
conservateur c'est vrai qu'en France ça
correspond pas à une véritable tradition
la différence on va en angle en
Grande-Bretagne il y a tout de suite un
parti conservateur même si on peut dire
il a changé c'est plus la même chose que
ce qu'il était au départ etc puisque en
gros être conservateur ça voulait dire
être favorable à la monarchie absolue
bon et être libéral c'était favorable à
une monarchie contrôlée limitée etc bon
on voit bien que chez nous c'est une
division qui marche pas bien
bon on prend les États-Unis
il y a des néoconservateurs chez les
républicains c'est la droite des
républicains bon mais on voit à peu près
c'est vrai que nous on a eu tendance à
opposer souvent ordre et Progrès ce qui
était une manière de bien poser les
choses et aujourd'hui bon ce qui est
vrai qui est compliqué quand on regarde
la droite c'est qu'elle est
effectivement tellement tiraillée entre
le macronisme d'un côté et l'extrême
droite de l'autre que très souvent elle
hésite et on le voit là où les débats
actuel en ce moment pour la présidence
de LR on va évidemment analyser ce ces
candidatures à la présence de de l'air
et le positionnement des uns et des
autres Laetitia se rejoint est-ce que
c'est on peut peut-être faire un peu
d'histoire
se rappeler où et quand le conservatisme
nait et puis peut-être aussi ça va faire
beaucoup en une seule réponse mais
pourquoi c'est un peu tabou en France
aujourd'hui à droite quoi c'est quand
même intéressant c'est exactement ce que
j'essayais de comprendre dans mon livre
le livre que vous avez cité qui date de
2016 en fait donc c'est c'est ça fait un
moment
je m'étais intéressé à la question parce
que je me demandais justement pourquoi
il n'y avait pas de conservatisme en
France
de fait j'ai dû regarder où il y en
avait et le berceau du conservatisme
vous l'avez cité c'est la
Grande-Bretagne ensuite les États-Unis
les Grande-Bretagne
18e 18e siècle alors c'est la
Grande-Bretagne alors il y a plusieurs
façons de dater le début officiel du
Parti conservateur c'est plutôt les
années 1800 mais aujourd'hui les
conservateurs britanniques estiment que
leur père fondateurs et Edmond Burke
Edmond Burke était un philosophe et un
député qui alors là ça devient très
compliqué était libéral donc oui et il
s'opposait au Tori qui sont aujourd'hui
les conservateurs en gros les théories
étaient très monarchistes ils étaient
pour en gros un très fort pouvoir
accordé au roi les wig voulaient que le
Parlement ait plus d'importance et ce
qui est fascinant dans l'histoire du
conservatisme anglais c'est pour ça que
il est très différent d'un conservatisme
réactionnaire c'est que ils ont réussi à
s'adapter progressivement en acceptant
donc les théories ont accepté de devenir
plus libéraux au plan économique et au
plan politique c'est pour ça que le
Parlement d'ailleurs est tellement fort
je reviens à la France pourquoi c'est ce
qu'on disait dans le sujet à l'instant
pourquoi c'est un tabou et bien parce
que l'histoire française s'est fait par
la rupture je ne vous apprends rien mais
1789 c'est une façon d'imposer le
libéralisme enfin d'accéder au
libéralisme par la rupture pourquoi
parce qu'en face on a une monarchie qui
ne veut pas céder je simplifie tout le
XIXe siècle c'est ça aussi ce sont ce
qu'on appelle les légitimistes c'est à
dire en gros les royalistes mais bon qui
qui se retrouvent un petit peu dans leur
coin qui luttent contre l'idée libérale
donc c'est le contraire de ce qui s'est
passé au Royaume-Uni pour avoir un vrai
grand parti conservateur je pense qu'il
aurait fallu déjà qu'on est une histoire
d'appropriation et de mélange entre
conservatisme et libéralisme qui est
très difficile à comprendre pour la
droite française qui n'est pas un parti
conservateur alors bien sûr après on
regarde l'Union européenne quand on fait
des catégories en politique ou en
sociologie on est obligé on peut on peut
considérer que le R l'UMP LR sont des
parties conservateurs mais vous voyez
qu'il n'arrive il n'arrive pas à rendre
les deux pôles conservatisme libéralisme
c'est-à-dire en gros adaptation au
changement mais pas trop rapide il
n'arrive pas à rendre ces deux pôles
compatibles et c'est un peu dramatique
parce que c'est parce que du coup ça
fait partie les uns les uns vont vers le
centre du type Emmanuel Macron en marche
philosophes vont plus à droite du type
Éric Zemmour ou à la rigueur Marine Le
Pen mais là on est dans le populisme ce
qui est un petit peu autre chose
justement
qui se réclame le plus du conservatisme
aujourd'hui ou qui coche le plus de
cases du conservatisme dans le paysage
politique français si on reprend
l'actualité politique récente il me
semble qu'Eric Zemmour cochée pas mal de
cases dans sa campagne de 2022 et en
particulier cela dimension que Frédéric
maton t'y rappelait que cette dimension
au fond de retour en arrière
fondamental chez Éric Zemmour l'idée que
c'était mieux avant l'idée que nous
perdu la boussole à un moment donné on
sait pas quand d'ailleurs ils ne le date
jamais et exactement mais c'est toujours
cette idée qu'à un moment donné il y
aurait eu une rupture dans l'identité
fondamentale de la société française et
je pense que cette dimension de cette
ému avant on a perdu la boussole et et
il faut essayer de coûte que coûte de
retrouver le code génétique qui a été
perdu quelque part est une idée
dans son clip de lancement
donc de ce point-là il coche beaucoup de
cases mais à l'intérieur de la famille
politique du centre droit et à l'Inter
des républicains vous avez aussi des
personnalités politiques qui vont être
plus conservatrices entre guillemets que
que d'autres on voit dans la compétition
aujourd'hui pour le parti pour prendre
la présidence du parti les LR
qu'effectivement quelqu'un comme Bruno
Retailleau c'est a voulu se caractériser
il a voulu se situer un petit peu dans
on va dire dans la trajectoire de cette
de cette droite de l'Ouest de la France
dont il est originaire et la cultivé
beaucoup ça alors il est un personnage
beaucoup plus compliqué que ça on peut
pas le résumer évidemment à cette seule
cette seule dimension mais voilà on voit
que relativement alors c'est vrai que si
on prend une dimension absolue qui est
le conservatisme entre guillemets
français par rapport à l'histoire des
idées politiques ou à l'histoire du
conservatif au Royaume-Uni aux
États-Unis effectivement ça n'est pas la
même chose mais si on prend quelque
chose de relatif c'est dans l'espace
politique français il y a bien des
partis politiques et des personnalités
politiques qui s'inscrivent dans un pôle
qu'on pourrait qualifier de pratiquement
conservateur c'est-à-dire l'idée que la
société est en train de perdre sa
boussole morale et alors ce qui est
vraiment intéressant et nous on le
constat dans nos données
d'enquête auprès des auprès des Français
on voit que certains traits du
conservatisme vont bien au-delà dans
l'opinion publique que les seuls
segments du système partisan ou de la
vie politique qui pourrait se
revendiquer vraiment comme voulant
incarner cette ce mieux c'était mieux
avant etc il y a un certain nombre de
dimensions et en particulier
qu'on aurait perdu la boussole morale
dans le pays qui est quand même très
très
partagé dans beaucoup de segments de
l'opinion dans une partie importante de
l'opinion est-ce que Frédéric mathoni le
conservatisme en France mais peut-être
aussi en Europe il y a d'autres exemples
européens alors je sais bien que c'est
pas le terme que vous employez mais
est-ce que effectivement il est d'abord
culturel ou identitaire même pour pour
dire les mots alors ce que dit Bruno
cotress c'est-à-dire le côté c'était
mieux avant où on ne peut plus rien dire
par exemple ça c'est des marqueurs
extrêmement forts de cette droite qu'on
appelle conservatrice réactionnaire
identitaire bon et c'est vrai que le le
culturel est très souvent la cible de
ces protestations c'était très frappant
dans le clip d'Éric Zemmour où on voyait
une France qui n'a jamais existé des
années 60 idéalisées en noir et blanc
etc avec Jean Gabin je sais plus mais
c'était vraiment une vision aux
États-Unis on voit très bien comment par
exemple
il y a une opposition très forte des
néoconservateurs ou des républicains
trumpistes par exemple contre Disney où
ils estiment que Disney c'est un lieu de
multiculturalisme dangereux qui fait
perdre les repères donc oui je pense que
la culture est un est un lieu de disons
que c'est un axe de controverse c'est là
où on fabrique des controvers c'est là
où on marque des points on le voit très
bien dans la façon dont les débats
publics c'est des lieux de enfin on l'a
vu là par exemple avec le jeu sur l'anti
fascisme
qui a été retiré à la FNAC pour quelques
jours c'est encore une fois par le
prisme culturel que ça fonctionne c'est
vraiment des lieux de fabrication de
controverses et c'est des lieux aussi ou
progressivement parce que ça marche
aussi comme ça la gauche recule alors
vous avez évoqué Bruno Retailleau je
vous propose qu'on regarde tout de suite
justement le tout début de son de son
clip de campagne voilà Bruno Retailleau
sénateur de Vendée vous avez fait
référence évidemment président du groupe
lrsi au Sénat voilà comment ça démarre
pourquoi je crois encore à la droite
parce que malgré nos épreuves la droite
porte toujours en elle cette France que
je porte en moi
cette France de l'honneur des combats
qu'on mène jusqu'au bout parce que pour
un pays comme pour un parti rien ne peut
tenir debout sans ces convictions qui
nous tiennent et vous les militants de
la droite vous avez tenu
[Musique]
cette France des valeurs aussi du
travail qui rend digne de l'audace qui
rend libre des racines qui rendent
fortes car être de droite c'est toujours
être de quelque part je suis mavandé ma
petite patrie charnelle dont les grandes
blessures et les grandes figures ont
appris à aimer notre grande patrie
française
oui je suis de cette France là oui je
suis de cette droite là fière parce que
notre histoire est grande fidèle parce
que la loyauté est belle malgré les
trahisons malgré les déceptions
nos déceptions
il y a quelques pics aussi on les a bien
vu avec le visage d'Édouard Philippe qui
apparaît au moment où le mot trahison
est prononcé mais moi je retiens aussi
ces images de Gaulle à Libération 44 la
liberté guidée dans le peuple de la
croix il y a Notre Dame il y a un
général royaliste de la gare de Vendée
la galerie des Glaces évidemment le
château de Versailles de Lattre de
Tassigny bref on va pas tout tous les
citer Laetitia se rejoins est-ce que
tout ça ce sont des codes conservateurs
on peut l'imaginer mais est-ce que pour
autant ça réduit Bruno Retailleau à se
qualificatif vous voyez ce que je veux
dire parce que c'est complexe en fait
une candidature politique alors la
difficulté c'est que pour moi
conservateur n'est pas un n'est pas un
gros mot
quand vous dites est-ce que ça réduit
un conservateur moi je être réduit un
conservateur si c'est assez riche et
s'il y a beaucoup de thèmes je vous
décrivais le conservatisme britannique
ça peut être une pensée politique bien
sûr très profonde d'ailleurs sauf qu'il
y a peu on a comme pardon nous
interrompre mais on a on a peu d'hommes
de droite qui
accepte d'être défini comme conservateur
enfin on y revient à ça les raisons
historiques qu'on a défini je voulais
juste dire un point sur Zemmour j'ai une
petite divergence avec vous moi je ne
pense pas pas que ce soit un
conservateur pour moi c'est
réactionnaire un conservatoire c'est
quelqu'un qui
n'est pas contre le changement il est
contre un changement trop rapide c'est
quelqu'un qui cherche le bon rythme de
la réforme et donc c'est quelqu'un qui
normalement est au fait des évolutions
sociales et c'est vrai que parfois il
peut estimer que la gauche peut aller
trop loin trop vite mais
fondamentalement
de Gaulle est un bon exemple alors après
ce qui rendent complètement dans la
catégorie conservateur on peut en
discuter des heures mais c'est quelqu'un
qui avait compris justement qu'en France
il y avait des envies d'ordre et des
envies de progrès alors après on
l'associe à un homme de droite mais oui
bien sûr ça va ça va c'est compatible on
peut on peut défendre ce conservatisme
là et être de droite j'ajouterai aussi
autre chose par rapport à Éric Zemmour
il y a quelque chose qui est très fort
c'est Éric Zemmour une forme de mépris
aussi de l'état de droit c'est à dire
aussi à mépris de l'individu du droit
qui attache à l'individu vis-à-vis du
droit de la raison d'État par exemple on
a l'impression qu'on pourrait examour la
raison des tas le sort de la France
passe bien avant le sort de l'individu
et que si l'individu doit se sacrifier
pour ça ça ne pose aucun problème dans
un vrai conservatisme qui pour moi
devrait être libéral
on ne peut pas oublier l'individu et
normalement la droite française telle
qu'elle existe aujourd'hui et je pense
que Monsieur Retailleau est de celle là
il y a un respect du droit il y a un
respect de l'État de droit on est très
loin quand même à mon avis des
propositions de quelqu'un comme
Eric Zemmour oui je suis plutôt d'accord
avec vous mais Frédéric Madani ce qui
est intéressant c'est que là on vient de
citer deux deux mots
conservatisme et libéralisme et ces deux
mots que quasiment personne n'emploie à
droite parce que c'est pareil il y a
très peu de politique de droite qui se
libéraux
oui parce que libéraux c'est toujours
entendu comme plutôt ultra libéral pour
aller vite et donc même si on fait une
politique
ultralibérale on ne revendique pas qu'on
fait une politique
ultra libérale Emmanuel Macron va jamais
dire qu'il est ultra libéral par exemple
pourtant c'est l'impression que depuis 2
ans et la crise covid se soit de l'ultra
libéralisme c'est une manière de c'est
une manière effectivement d'endiguer les
difficultés très bien que à chaque fois
il y a quelqu'un comme Bruno Le Maire
qui vient dire oui mais attention il va
falloir payer l'addition et payer
l'addition c'est quand même rogner sur
l'état providence en gros donc oui c'est
quand même bien la réforme de on voit
bien la réforme du chômage tout ça bon
bref quand même le pays d'Europe ou
l'État-providence a été le plus
protecteur depuis on peut pas faire
comme si ça n'avait pas eu très très
protecteur mais on voit bien le
détricotage qui est en train de se faire
et quand on est dans les services
publics et quand on est face à un
service public on va très très bien ce
que c'est que une politique de
limitation des enfin de des trucs je
sais pas comment on peut dire ça des
tricotage le service public je reviens à
la droite et à ce alors ce deuxième
tabou qui est le tabou du mot libéral
parce que en France un libéral il est
forcément ultra libéral c'est ça si vous
regardez ce que dit ici Bruno Retailleau
par exemple il y a plein de marqueurs
qui qui le mettent très à droite quand
même par exemple Patrice charnel
la patrie charnelle quand même ça nous
amène il fait la différence entre c'est
une façon de dire je suis pas d'abord
vendéen je suis français
alors que de la croix c'est pas dans le
patrimoine enfin la liberté de la croix
c'est pas dans le patrimoine de la
droite mais sur les mots tabous la
droite ne se dit pas non plus très de
droite si on sait rare de voir un homme
politique dire ou une femme politique
dire je suis de droite c'est c'est pas
non plus un terme qu'on emploie beaucoup
d'ailleurs c'est c'est très intéressant
de voir comment la droite précisément
euphémisme toujours c'est appartenants
ce conservatisme libérales de droite etc
alors c'est peut-être un de ces
problèmes
la question assez assez compliqué c'est
qu'on peut pas non plus réduire notre
vie politique à une seule dimension en
fait quand on prend en compte les deux
dimensions c'est à dire les dimensions
interventionnisme libéralisme au plan
économique plus la dimension
conservative libéralisme son plan des
valeurs et culture là on voit que ça se
complexifie et si on positionne Éric
Zemmour nous c'est ce qu'on a fait au
cevipov qui était de faire une étude
assez détaillée on va dire de l'offre
politique de la présidentielle avec
encodant les candidats sur tout un tas
de dimensions on voyait que Éric Zemmour
s'inscrivait économiquement du même côté
qu'Emmanuel Macron mais culturellement
du même côté que Marine Le Pen et donc
on voit qu'effectivement de ce point de
vent on peut pas les ranger dans des
boîtes extrêmement simples qu'on dise
qu'il est réactionnaire conservateur
conservateur réactionnaire etc et c'est
ça qui rend en fait la situation de la
droite aujourd'hui c'est dramatique pour
eux aussi et si compliqué c'est que de
ce point de vue là ils sont pris en étau
de partout du fait de ces deux du fait
de ces deux dimensions et c'est vrai que
la dernière fois que dans notre vie
politique la dimension de libéralisme
économique c'est fortement affirmé c'est
sans aucun doute lors de la première
cohabitation en 1986 lorsqu'on a une
droite qui vient au pouvoir sous la
présence de François Mitterrand portée
par une génération de jeunes cadres
d'ingénieurs qui à l'époque s'appelle
euh François Léotard par exemple ou
d'autres personnalités politiques qui à
ce moment-là veulent dire nous on est
des libéraux et il y a pas de honte être
libéral dans la dans la société
française et l'échec au fond de ce
projet de ce projet politique par la
réélection de François Mitterrand en
1988 et l'impossibilité derrière pour la
droite de offrir à nouveau une solution
qui ne soit qu'une solution libérale est
effectivement de ce point de vue là
intéressant et vous avez raison il y a
pratiquement plus aucune personnalité
politique qui revendique l'étendard je
suis un libéral où je suis un
conservateur je me souviens une photo de
ces cadra qui était tous sans cravate
Seguin sans doute
je pense que c'était quand même beaucoup
d'opportunisme pareil chez Rick Zemmour
Éric Zemmour na ne s'interse absolument
pas à l'économie la liberté économique
ne l'intéresse pas dans ses fondements
philosophiques il y a de quoi s'y
intéresser vraiment il y a des choses
passionnantes on a des on a on a des
libéraux
on a Jean-Baptiste c'est Frédéric Bastia
enfin si on veut vraiment s'intéresser
au libéralisme économique français il y
a de quoi faire Éric Zemmour ça l'ennui
profondément et je pense qu'on ne peut
pas plaquer des convictions politiques
sur un programme pour le gagner vite
fait bien fait en quelques mois il faut
aussi qu'il y ait un historique dans un
parti et qui est un vrai attachement à
ces questions si c'est pour changer
d'avis un an plus tard enfin moi je
considère que la droite française n'a
jamais eu de conviction très profonde
sur ces sujets la cessé de changer
d'avis en fonction de ce qu'elle voyait
ce qu'elle comprenait de l'opinion c'est
pour ça que ça demande un travail énorme
qui n'est pas fourni aujourd'hui par la
droite parce que on l'a dit et elle
contient des éléments qui sont très
contradictoires qui ne comprennent pas
pourquoi ils sont ensemble moi je pense
qu'on peut arriver à définir des raisons
pour lesquelles il pourrait être
ensemble parce que à mon avis la droite
est légitime a existé on en a besoin
entre les extrêmes et et le parti
d'Emmanuel Macron qui n'est pas
complètement de à mon avis et c'est
assez dangereux pour tout le monde je
pense même pour la gauche il n'y ait pas
de vraie droite alors on va Laetitia
vous quand on a commencé à travailler
sur cette question ce débat sur le le
conservatif vous êtes parti un peu plus
vous avez élargi un peu le la réflexion
en disant mais la société française elle
est carrément bipolaire pourquoi vous
dites oui je veux dire ça parce que là
vous ne connaissez vous venez justement
d'évoquer cette finalement cette
confrontation entre le social et
l'économie et c'est précisément moi ce
que je vais vous démontrer là maintenant
je vais tenter de le faire c'est comme
si la société française finalement avait
deux cerveaux un cerveau droit
progressiste sur les questions
sociétales type mariage pour tous
IVG
procréation médicalement assistée pour
des femmes seules ou lesbiennes et puis
un cerveau gauche totalement
recroquevillé sur les acquis sociaux ok
il ne faut surtout pas toucher alors
même que la société évolue qu'on vit
plus longtemps qu'on vit plus
confortablement je précise quand même
que quand je dis cerveau droit et gauche
je fais absolument pas allusion au bord
politique c'est une image nécessaire à
la pédagogie voyez-vous donc la société
française serait conservatrice si je me
suis bien notamment au sujet des
retraites bah on ne peut que constater
le blocage de la société sur l'âge légal
de départ à la retraite je rappelle que
c'est une promesse Emmanuel Macron que
normalement ce serait 65 ans à l'horizon
2031 mon sang déjà que la rentrée 2023
Thomas elle risque d'être très tendu sur
le sujet aucun syndicat n'accepte ce
rapport d'âge et les Français dans leur
grande majorité non plus un des derniers
sondages par exemple c'était celui de
yugov pour le Off post c'était en
octobre annoncé que deux Français sur 3
66% ne voulait pas de la réforme près de
la moitié de la population 48% il serait
tout à fait défavorable et seulement
8%, il serait favorable alors on a déjà
consacré à 10 heures de débat sur ce
plateau on va pas revenir sur le détail
de cette réforme je constate simplement
que sur ce sujet du travail il y a oui
un certain conservatisme et là plutôt de
gauche alors certains vous diront au
contraire que le conservatisme c'est
justement dans le travail plus oui c'est
l'argument phare de la gauche mais là je
préfère vous parler de l'opinion
publicité Bruno cotreesse la société
française dans son ensemble et tous les
experts s'accordent à dire que elle
s'est droitisé cette société vous êtes
d'accord Thomas depuis la présidentielle
on entend que cela il a il y a eu un
bascule à droite la France a basculé à
droite alors pourquoi ça bloque sur les
retraites la société française et
bipolaire je ne vois que ça c'est soit
un paradoxe soit un charme ça dépend du
point de vue en tous les cas c'est
surprenant Bruno Cotterêts j'aimerais
bien vous entendre sur ce sujet de
remarque la première c'est
qu'effectivement on a dans toutes les
données d'opinion cette dualité et à la
fois une société française qui voit la
société française principalement comme
une société profondément injuste nous
avions demandé il y a deux ans aux
personnes qu'on interroge dans notre
baromètre de confiance politique quel
était le mot qui pourrait caractériser
le mieux la manière dont la société
française les traiter eux
individuellement c'était le mépris voilà
donc une perception d'une société
française injuste qui ne tient pas à sa
promesse d'égalité républicaine la
méritocratie en panne l'escalope
l'escalier social en donc avec une
demande considérable que quelque chose
se passe pour déverrouiller et débloquer
la société française et dans le même
temps effectivement des aspirations qui
vont plus sur le sécurité
quelques quelques chiffres récents je ne
me reconnais plus dans les valeurs de la
société française dont on a 67 % de
personnes interrogées qui adhèrent à
cette à cette idée on est allé trop loin
dans la promotion des droits des
minorités on a quand même 26% des gens
qui disent ça donc on voit effectivement
cette dualité il y a un deuxième aspect
le deuxième aspect c'est le rapport au
temps quand on regarde le temps dans une
très longue distance on voit
qu'effectivement sur une très longue
distance au cours des 40 dernières
années la société française est devenue
beaucoup plus tolérante c'est ce que
démontre un de mes collègues de Sciences
Po 20 centimériques qui montrent
qu'effectivement la tolérance on va dire
culturelle c'est augmenter dans la
société française depuis les dernières
décennies et puis on a des accidents de
parcours des retours de bâtons culturels
avec aujourd'hui beaucoup de crises qui
se sont qui se sont passées et certaines
offres politiques et se mettre en place
vous savez il faut jamais non plus
négliger la capacité ou l'incapacité de
certains partis politiques à aller
capter ce qui se passe dans l'opinion en
faire quelque chose et de temps en temps
on a une formation politique en
l'occurrence aujourd'hui rassemblement
national ça a été aussi un peu le cas
d'Eric Zemmour pendant la présidentielle
qui arrive à capter une tendance de
l'opinion et la traduire politiquement
ce qui nous donne le sentiment d'une
société dans ce coup très conservatrice
alors que quand on regarde sur un très
long terme on voit que la société
devenue plutôt les rente Laetitia Stroch
Bonar il se peut y avoir un
conservatisme de gauche en quelque sorte
oui alors je voulais réagir ce que vous
disiez mais là vous me posez plutôt la
question sur la question sur
l'immobilisme je pense que ça c'est
prendre le terme de conservateur un peu
au pied de la lettre c'est une
définition qui n'est pas la définition
du Larousse par rapport à laquelle j'ai
commencé le débat c'est-à-dire que si on
cherche une définition historique et
politique c'est difficile de considérer
que c'est du conservatif
au sens qu'on l'a développé ensemble
donc je là dessus je ne dirais pas que
c'est du conservatisme de gauche après
existe-t-il un conservatisme de gauche
ça c'est autre chose vous trouvez des
auteurs oui qui défendent
oui possiblement une vision par exemple
très ancrée sur le local les traditions
les spécificités
locales et qui sont plutôt de gauche il
y a des conservateurs de gauche par
exemple aux États-Unis je pense à un
historien qui s'appelle Christopher la
hache enfin qui qui est mort qui était
un conservateur
en tout cas que la droite ne considérait
pas comme de droite
de gauche pour les Américains parce que
c'est pas là aussi voilà c'est difficile
je sais pas si nos auditeurs le
connaissent mais à ce qu'on attendrait
de quelqu'un de droite c'est-à-dire
notamment sur le rapport à l'autorité
des choses comme ça ou c'est pas du tout
un sujet qui l'intéressait de gauche
parce que par exemple je coupe juste
Laurent Berger pas trop mais
taxé les autres syndicats à quantités et
c'était agit de parler du dialogue
social en entreprise de trop
conservateur oui mais ça tous les autres
c'est plutôt un jeu de mots sur un terme
qui est mal vu en France donc il suffit
de taxer son opposante conservateur mais
moi je ne vois pas de de teneur
politique je ne sais pas si tous les
Français ont votre défense en tête ils
ont si les Français veulent appeler ça
du conservatisme ils le peuvent mais là
on est en train de chercher ensemble à
définir une certaine droite il me semble
et son rapport au progrès en fait voilà
mais je je dis pas que ce que j'étais
faux mais c'est pas forcément
dans ce que vous avez dit là ce que vous
avez appelé le conservatisme
c'est-à-dire vous avez à la fois ou
plutôt au départ vous avez parlé de
progressif vous avez mis des droits
c'est-à-dire l'IVG la paix bah le
mariage pour tous et puis d'un coup vous
nous avez expliqué touché à l'âge de la
retraite et donc augmenter l'âge de la
retraite le refuser de le faire ce
serait conservateur oubliez que c'était
un pays européens
c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas ce que je
voulais c'est à dire il faut quand même
pas oublier que la retraite ça d'abord
été un droit et un droit arraché et de
manière extrêmement difficile et donc
faire comme si défendre ce droit c'était
du conservatif mais c'est quand même un
tour de passe-passe parce qu'en plus
vous avez dit l'âge l'âge de de augmente
le vieillissement d'abord c'est pas vrai
on voit bien que l'âge en bonne santé la
période où on est en bonne santé là je
recule enfin là je on est de plus en
plus souvent malade tôt en particulier
ce qu'on est travaux les plus pénibles
et qui sont à qui on va demander des
durées de cotisation beaucoup plus
importantes donc je vois pas trop ce que
serait de conservateur de défendre des
dire une caissière qu'elle va travailler
jusqu'à 65 ans bon je vois pas ce que ça
a progressiste en fait les arguments aux
uns les autres parce que je veux pas
relancer un débat effectivement autour
de l'âge de la retraite on l'a fait
plusieurs fois ils étaient passionnants
mais on va pas se relancer la dent en
revanche on sait poser forcément la
question et table traduit il va pouvoir
nous rejoindre sur ce plateau rebonsoir
table du Sénat alors là ça vous a
demandé à un travail de recherche
historique notamment qu'on peut saluer
ici le Sénat est-il conservateur voilà
un sujet de dissertation est 3 minutes
pour tenter d'y répondre alors tout
d'abord c'est un qualificatif qui lui a
été accolé par le passé on a parlé de
Sénat conservateur c'était le nom du
Sénat lorsqu'il a été ressuscité par
Napoléon alors conçu en 1799 un sénat
inspiré de l'antique inspiré de celui de
Rome son rôle alors c'est de conserver
la constitution de veiller au respect de
la loi fondamentale et puis ensuite ça
va être même de la modifier au départ ce
sont
sages des membres inamovibles qui ne
sont pas élus mais nommés et qui sont
choyés par le régime à savoir que on
leur octroyait des revenus très
confortables et même un palais
résidentiel et qui se montrent donc en
contrepartie ces sages et bien
extrêmement docile on va avancer un
petit peu dans l'histoire le Sénat c'est
ensuite une revendication des
monarchistes en 1870 c'est ainsi qu'il
se constitue comme une assemblée de
notables locaux instament quelque chose
que l'on retrouve aujourd'hui dans son
ADN et noter que sous la Troisième
République Léon Blum le qualifie je le
cite de chambre d'ajournement
systématique il faut dire qu'à l'époque
et ben il n'y avait pas de limite à la
navette parlementaire et que certaines
réformes mettaient donc plusieurs années
à être à adopté grâce à la lenteur
sénatoriale le Sénat est donc associé à
un conservatisme impénitent un frein
constant au progrès un opposant
permanent c'est ce qui explique dans son
livre sur le Sénat l'ancien garde des
sceaux Jean-Jacques Urvoas est-ce qu'on
peut dire aujourd'hui que le Sénat est
conservateur en tout cas la doit être la
droite la majoritaire ça c'est sûr
depuis 1858 le début de la cinquième la
droite il règne en mètre 158
le politologue Benjamin Morel le centre
droit à l'acception d'une courte
parenthèse qu'il y a eu entre 2011 et
2014 ou le Sénat basculer à gauche et
bien la chambre haute a toujours été
majoritairement dans cette tendance que
Benjamin Morel résume ainsi c'est la
droite démocrate chrétienne des
territoires qui va bien et qui est donc
majoritaire donc ça s'explique par le
mode de scrutin qui sur-repente les
territoires ruraux ces territoires qui
votent plutôt à droite par rapport au
territoire urbain qui votent plus à
gauche lors des dernières élections
c'était notamment écologiste et c'est
donc pour ça que Lionel Jospin avait
parlé d'anomalie démocratique lorsqu'il
dit ça en 2008 et bien elle dénonce le
mode de scrutin du Sénat qui fait de
cette assemblée il le dit une chambre
conservatrice écoutez-le sans expliquer
c'était sur notre antenne en 2011
il y a deux types de seconde chambre il
y a les secondes chambres des états
fédéraux c'est les États-Unis c'est
l'Allemagne
et ces deux secondes chambres sont élus
au suffrage universel elle représente la
diversité d'un pays fédéral et puis il y
a des chambres
héritées des vieilles chambres
aristocratiques qui sont devenus des
chambres conservatrices
et c'est à cette deuxième catégorie qui
appartient
voilà l'ancien Premier ministre
incrimine dans le mode de scrutin à la
fois la sur-représentation des très
petites communes le fait que la chambre
soit élue par un suffrage indirect par
160 000 grands électeurs à 95% des mers
des conseillers municipaux ça s'explique
parce que le Sénat représente
constitutionnellement les territoires
notaient quand même que depuis cette
critique le mode de scrutin il a été
réformé le favorise un peu moins
aujourd'hui la ruralité est-ce que le
Sénat a des positions conservatrices sur
la loi les lois qu'il va sur les sujets
sociétaux ça c'est assez clair sur la
constitutionnalisation de l'IVG sur
l'allongement du délai légal pour avoir
le droit de faire une IVG sur les
récents textes de bioéthique ce sont des
sujets sur lesquels le Sénat a plutôt
freiné des quatre fers mais dans son
côté conservateur et bien il y a aussi
le côté protectorial côté défense de
liberté publique ça c'est comme un
discours qu'il a de façon très très
forte la liberté d'aller venir la
liberté de la presse ou encore la
liberté d'entreprendre en tout cas
aujourd'hui on est très loin de cette
image dont je parlais au début celle de
Léon Blum qui parlait du Sénat comme
d'un empêcheur de tourner en rond son
mode de scrutin lui permet aujourd'hui
d'être indépendant des vagues générés
par la présidentielle et les
législatives le résultat est
dernièrement c'est que lorsque
l'assemblée était acquise à la
République en marchant 2017 bien le
Sénat était de droite aujourd'hui alors
que le que l'assemblée est fracturé sans
majorité absolue bien le Sénat est de
droite c'est donc un phare de droite
dans une tempête un pôle de stabilité
dit certains sénateurs une opposition
constructive dit Gérard Larcher et puis
je vais citer aussi Maurice Schumann qui
est l'un des pères de l'Europe mais qui
a aussi été je l'ai découvert 24 ans
sénateurs il avait une expression que
les sénateurs aiment beaucoup reprendre
elle disait le Sénat c'est l'édit de
Nantes permanent de la République voilà
face au bruit elle a fureur récente à
l'Assemblée bien le Sénat c'est devenu
une force conservatrice pacificatrice et
parfois motrice pour le gouvernement qui
a pu s'appuyer sur cette chambre pour
faire passer certains textes récemment
merci beaucoup Tam traduis c'était
passionnant Bruno cot parce que le Sénat
est le fief conservateur par excellence
que j'aime bien là définition le résumé
qu'on a donné Benjamin Morel la droite
démocrate chrétienne des territoires qui
vont bien sauf que ça va bien au Sénat
et c'est vrai que le Sénat aujourd'hui a
pris évidemment si Lionel Jospin raison
de pointer les
héritages historiques on voit qu'on est
aujourd'hui dans quelque chose d'autre
avec ce Sénat qui est plus cette chambre
qui veut représenter un peu l'équilibre
c'est vrai que sur des réformes de
société ils ont bloqué plusieurs fois
les réformes institutionnelles voulues
par Emmanuel Macron ça c'est absolument
absolument certain mais dans le même
temps c'est vrai que ça joue cette
institution un peu d'équilibre et qui
veut en particulier
se préoccuper des questions de liberté
des questions de territoire donc de ce
point de là je dirais que c'est sans
doute une chambre qui n'est pas de même
majorité que l'Assemblée nationale mais
que je ne qualifierai pas de
conservatrice
aujourd'hui on va élargir notre débat en
lin un tout petit peu évoqué et il nous
reste quoi 7 8 minutes à d'autres piges
je vous propose d'écouter la nouvelle
présidente du Conseil italien
d'un Premier ministre c'est un extrait
d'un discours qu'elle avait fait en
français pendant sa campagne électorale
victorieuse elle avait pas encore été
désigné elle parle justement de
conservatisme Georgia Meloni et puis des
années j'ai également
de présider les parties des
conservateurs européens qui partagent
des valeurs et des expériences avec les
toris britanniques les républicains
américains et les liquidiens alors c'est
dans ce même discours que qu'elle avait
affirmé que le fascisme appartient à
l'histoire Laetitia strange Bonnard
c'est vous l'avez un peu évoqué mais
elle elle fait référence autorise
britannique aux républicain américain
hollywo israélien est-ce qu'il y a une
espèce d'international du conservatisme
je fais volontairement le jeu de mots
c'est très compliqué d'autant que les
mouvements consternateurs sont très liés
aux histoires nationales et qu'en plus
eux-mêmes mettent l'accent sur les
histoires nationales et l'héritage
national donc parler d'une
internationale
des formes différentes d'un pays à
l'autre c'est ça aussi ils peuvent
s'entendre entre eux je pense mais il y
a aussi des incompréhensions
fondamentales notamment le rôle par
exemple du libéralisme économique pour
les conservateurs américains alors avec
Trump c'est un petit peu changé mais
c'était une donnée fond mental c'est un
petit peu différent si vous prenez la
Hongrie de Victor bah oui vous avez
avoir des nuances bon qui les empêchent
pas de se parler alors le cas de mélodie
est compliqué je trouve parce que il y a
chez elle des éléments de libéral
confirmatif j'ajoute libéral parce que
elle a quand même affiché son soutien à
l'Ukraine et normalement on n'attend pas
ça des réactionnaires des conservateurs
sur Youtube italienne et colossale et
qu'elle dépend de l'Europe non
il y a des formes de libéral
conservatisme mais il y a aussi des
tensions vers l'extrême droite au sens
où elle a un discours par exemple sur
l'identité italienne qui est peut-être
encore plus fort que ce qu'on peut
entendre en France sur l'identité
nationale alors ça vient aussi du cas de
l'Italie qui est très particulier où il
y a une insécurité culturelle encore
plus forte quand elle est ressentie que
chez nous donc voilà ce que je veux dire
par là c'est que je trouve très
difficile de situer cette cette femme
politique il faut il va falloir attendre
de voir ce qu'elle va faire concrètement
mais est-ce que c'est pas un mouvement
quand même je retiens ce que les abonnés
cotresses sur le la société française
cette demande finalement de retour à des
valeurs anciennes c'est inquiétude face
à je rejoins aussi inquiétude face aux
crises que l'on traverse de depuis des
années tout ça je l'imagine se retrouve
aussi dans vos enquêtes d'opinions mais
est-ce que ça pousse pas les
conservateurs pas seulement en France
d'ailleurs en Europe de basculer petit à
petit vers une droite un peu plus
extrême je voudrais ajouter quelque
chose en fait quand on est conservateur
on peut parler de même sujet que
l'extrême droite les populistes mais la
clé pour moi c'est qu'on en parle pas de
la même façon c'est pas seulement pour
l'apparence c'est qu'on ne voit pas la
chose de la même façon par exemple tiens
jamais le nid donc je parlais d'extrême
droite parle d'islamisation de l'Italie
ça normalement un conservateur libéral
britannique par exemple qui est pour moi
vous avez compris le modèle du
préservatif ne parlerai jamais comme ça
plutôt néo fascisme si elle se dit
conservation
quelques minutes avant la fin de
l'émission merci Bruno et à très bientôt
allez-y pardon vous avez un
c'est c'est extrêmement c'est beaucoup
plus intéressant pour elle que ce qu'on
lui accorde comme étiquette qui est la
véritable étiquette néo fasciste donc
elle a tout intérêt à se dire
conservatrice c'est un côté lustration
en fait
ça c'est pas sûr c'est ce que ça c'est
peut-être pas sûr mais en tout cas elle
elle a intérêt stratégiquement à
utiliser cette étiquette qui la rend
propre
elle a quand même un héritage elle a un
passé bon voilà et quand même il y a une
tentation enfin je l'ai vu chez il y a
une revue qui s'appelle le conservateur
qui est fabriqué par d'anciens
identitaires enfin des gens qui sont
vraiment très à l'extrême droite parce
que c'est une manière de de ne pas dire
qu'on est à l'extrême droite mais je
voulais dire laissons lui aussi le
bénéfice du doute parce que par exemple
sur l'Ukraine même si c'est totalement
opportuniste c'est plutôt bien enfin moi
ce qu'on voit effectivement c'est que
économiquement elle a plutôt tendance à
la donner des gages à l'Europe pour les
raisons qui évoquaient ici à l'instant
mais qu'en revanche elle va peut-être
pour donner des gages à celles et ceux
qui l'ont élus être pour le coup un peu
plus
en termes en termes culturel en terme
social sociétal dans dans le camp qui
était le son camp d'origine quoi vous
voyez ce que je veux dire oui mais je
reviens un petit peu à ce que je disais
tout à l'heure en effet alors peut-être
qu'elle ira plus à droite mais pour moi
on franchit le mur vers l'extrême droite
quand on se met à détricoter l'État de
droit et qu'on refuse aussi le
pluralisme ça c'est quelque chose de
très important et je pense qu'on peut
être de droite conservateurs et
respecter toutes ces notions mais c'est
vrai qu'en Europe on a aujourd'hui on ne
voit pas cette droite moi je ne la vois
pas je la cherche je vois beaucoup de de
peur et en effet au lieu la stratégie ça
devrait être de se rapprocher du centre
et de dire voilà ce qui nous différencie
quand même du centre sur un certain
nombre de questions or la stratégie qui
semble plutôt gagner c'est l'autre je
pense que c'est une erreur fondamentale
il ne gagneront jamais des voix en
faisant ça les parties de droits
merci beaucoup merci à toutes les trois
d'avoir participé à ce débat je vais
rappeler le titre de vos livres
respectifs Frédéric matthony comment
sommes-nous devenus réac alors il est
publié aux éditions fayards et Laetitia
strange Bona livre un peu plus ancien
effectivement c'est aux éditions du Cerf
vous avez dit conservateur voilà on
revoit la
page de garde la couverture de votre
livre merci encore je vous dis à demain
merci à toutes et à tous de votre
fidélité et on vous donne rendez-vous
sur l'antenne de Public Sénat la
matinale bonjour chez vous rien de
Mancini vous le voyez reçoit Jean-Marc
Ayrault l'ancien Premier ministre et le
président aujourd'hui de la Fondation
Jean Jaurès belle soirée à toutes et à
tous
[Musique]